jordan palmer quarterback coach draft
training expert
and uh just launched the qb summit
digital platform via
qbsummit.com and that's aimed at
training and growing youth and high
school aged quarterbacks
plus he works with a lot of these young
quarterbacks like sam darnold josh allen
joe burrow desean watson
and i figured that jordan would be a
great person to tap into
with these younger quarterbacks here uh
in particular trey lance
uh jordan good morning thanks for
joining us here's a kid at north dakota
state
28 touchdowns zero interceptions they
win their national title and they're
going to showcase him for one game this
year against central arkansas
how dangerous is it to showcase him
against central arkansas
and basically have a pro day that's
actually a game
well i love it i think it's smart um
it's obviously great for the program for
a lot of reasons that
are specific to the program but for trey
i think it presents a great opportunity
to
even though it's one game to back up a
lot of the hype that is
just getting started i mean like the
fact that we're talking about him on the
dan patrick
show that's kind of the start of of the
hype train
and so getting a chance to see him play
after he's received the hype
uh is i think it's gonna be a great
opportunity for him if i hadn't seen him
play
how would you describe his uh skill set
so i mean six three two twenty five so
he's not there's nothing uh he's not way
bigger and way stronger
than everybody else uh but he is i think
the
one of the best combinations of the
physical elements that you need
that i've seen in a long time so he is
on the bigger side he's on the faster
side he has a very quick release
he's very decisive with the ball a very
interesting stat line and
i have not seen this before he threw 28
touchdowns and no picks
he had almost 290 attempts i don't care
what level you're at
high school pop warner whatever
uh that many attempts without turning it
over and then on top of that he rushes
for like 1200 yards so
um he's just i think one of the better
packages
uh that we've seen and then the part
that you and a lot of the media members
will start to get to see over the next
year is that he's uh a great person he's
you know he's the kind uh guy he's also
a dynamic leader
he's kind of a dog when you get him on
the field so i think he's just
he's not in this one unique thing he's
just the one of the best packages we've
seen
we had kirk herb street on a couple of
weeks ago and i said
who would you take justin fields or
trevor lawrence
and he said you know now i'm talking
about going into the nfl and he said i'd
lean towards justin fields
over trevor lawrence what do you make of
that
um i think it's similar the the
questions around justin are the similar
ones that you're going to see around
trey lance and that
we just saw for one year you really only
did it for one year and unfortunately
ohio state's not playing and so
um i think there's more sample size with
trevor uh but at the same time
just because somebody played one year
doesn't mean that they're not going to
follow that up with 15 amazing ones
um so i can see why people would go with
justin fields but i have
uh similar questions with both those
guys and i have similar things that i
get really excited about with those guys
what's the biggest question though that
you have is it the same question
yeah i think with both those guys look
playing at a dominant
college football team when the majority
of the time you step on the field
you're favored to win okay and two is
the perfect example last year
pretty much every time two went on the
field at alabama they're supposed to win
right they're literally favored okay so
when you play the majority of your games
that way
we just don't know definitively how
you're going to play
when you are no longer favored and you
don't have the best team on the field so
you talk about sam darnold
there's a perfect example joe burrow
when he steps on the field
the bengals are not going to be favored
for 16 weeks this year
and so that's the biggest question mark
is does it translate can they be
the catalyst type player where they
literally make the whole team better as
opposed to just
execute things well when you're playing
out of clemson at ohio state alabama
you can just play well and be in the
running for the high school and you
worked out with uh joe burrow
and you know i don't know what that's
like when all of a sudden you go to
you're going to usually a team that's
been losing so he's going to the bengals
sam darnold went to the jets
you know josh allen went to the buffalo
bills you know they're they're not
winning
and these guys are coming from programs
for the most part where they were
winning
and how do what do you teach them or
tell them about that mental
or whatever it might be that hurdle that
says
you're not going to win as often as you
think and this is the role that you have
with your team
yeah i think uh the most important tree
there's really two this is where my eye
goes when i'm evaluating guys and then
when i'm advising
guys as they make that transition it
really comes down to
confidence and maturity and it's funny
because we make a huge deal out of arm
talent and stats and
it's 40-yard dash time and it comes down
to those two things confidence and
maturity
confidence it's uh it really has to be
there's two types of confidence there's
self-generated confidence where it's
independent of the environment i mean
i don't care what anybody says about me
good or bad this is what i believe about
myself
and then there's the reactionary
confidence which a lot of young players
have where if everybody says that you're
awesome they believe it
everybody says you're a bum you start to
wonder if they're right
on the maturity side of things it's not
about tucking your shirt in and saying
yes sir and being on time what it is is
being in a new situation for the first
time and acting as if
you've been in that situation multiple
times and so i look at joe burrow last
year
the he yeah he went to ohio state and
all that but that run
when they're 7-0 at lsu an 8-0 and 11-0
and 12-0 and it starts to get really big
right
and then the heisman and all the media
and all the stuff that comes with that
he handled all of that as if he as if it
was his third time doing it
and so when you go to the league and
there's all this newness
the franchise you're now a professional
there's all the the responsibility all
the newness
of the nfl when they when the mature
guys
handle it as if it's their third or
fourth year we're seeing that with
patrick we've seen that with deshawn
we're seeing that with josh we see it
with a lot of these guys and so that's
what i really try and look for in these
college guys when we're projecting what
is it about that second year jump that
we've seen
and it's expected of kyler murray this
year you saw that with lamar jackson
last year you saw that with patrick
mahomes as well
what what is it that some quarterbacks
see and other ones don't
well i i use that word newness because
as a fan you know you think about
the newness is uh well they see
different coverages now you know people
play different defenses and they've got
new teammates
but everything's new they're no longer a
student athlete
these guys live change their lives
changed so much off the field
that it's overwhelming for guys and i'm
uniquely positioned to have this opinion
because i i'm
for some of these guys i'm the ones
advising them and there's something
about that second year once you've
gotten
a lot of that newness out of the way
where it can now get
just back to football just back to x's
and o's and executing
and getting on time with that guy and
understanding that coverage it gets
you get all the new stuff out of the way
and it gets to be just football
like it was in college but what happened
to baker mayfield who was
good year one regressed year two and
what do you expect in year three
so year two there's just no continuity
that move to bring it to
to promote freddie kitchens based off of
some relationship that baker and him had
and you know one of the guys that was
actually the really the mastermind
and really helpful in baker's rookie
year his name is ken zampeezy he was a
quarterback coach
he wasn't a part of that he was out so
now you've got freddie kitchens and
drew stanton and some people who are
know a lot of football and can be really
helpful and great coaches
um but that continuity and that um the
responsibility that they put on baker i
think that that was just
that was poorly timed with uh or coupled
with a ton of expectations
we all looked at that roster obj and we
expected these things up here
but they didn't have the foundation i
actually do think they have it this year
and i think baker uh has the best year
that he's had in the nfl coming up i
think he actually has a monster here
he's jordan palmer quarterback coach
draft training expert if
you were running the dolphins if you're
coach flores
you starting who week one i start ryan
fitzpatrick
i played with ryan fitzpatrick i think
two is gonna be a great pro i just don't
see the value in uh
going you know forcing two on the field
and i don't know i'm not in these
practices i don't know if he's ready
right now but
either way i'm all i'm a big proponent
of all these guys sitting if they can
but more importantly if they can sit
behind
a guy like ryan fitzpatrick or josh
mccown or
alex smith if they can sit behind a guy
like that
i think all of them should sit because
there's too much value in watching not
just ryan play but ryan work
ryan deal with adversity and you also
get a chance if your floor is
to let let your team settle in through a
few weeks
right you're gonna find out how good or
bad you are we'll do that with ryan so
you can put two in it whatever you think
is the perfect time
jordan just launched the qb summit
digital platform via
qbsummit.com so this is helping uh
youth quarterbacks high school
quarterbacks
what's the one thing you teach that or
that you want them to take away from
this experience
well you know it's an online platform
the hardest thing right now in the
country is and
this is launched internationally as well
is access to
quality quarterback coaching we're
seeing the position all different kinds
of guys
from all different parts of the country
there's a kid in germany committed to
tcu so literally all parts of the world
wow
these quarterbacks are developing and
it's getting harder and harder to
separate yourself and so for me
um i launched these platforms for the
guys that they have a coach
they go to camps um as young as 10 years
old and
you know i work with 10-year vets but
these kids they can actually take this
and add this to their game so
i've got a content for everything in
there but the focus is is
trying to get them to be as confident as
possible i mentioned it's the most
important trait in a quarterback
i believe that confidence is a muscle
you can train it some of the things i do
with nfl guys is the same stuff i get a
chance to do with young guys so
this online platform is great for kids
coaches and also parents too
and it feels like that's russell
wilson's strongest trait
is he's mentally i think that he
he feels like he's stronger than you he
expects to win he expects to be great
and that's not always easy to do with
that position
lost your first second i think you're
talking about russell wilson yeah just
how mentally
strong he is he he thinks he's better
than you he thinks he's going to find a
way to win
can you teach that 100 and actually the
person who does his name's trevor moad
and that's who i've worked with for over
a decade he's a performance psychologist
got an amazing book out right now
uh that russell wrote the forward on it
um it's called it takes what it takes
and uh and so russell's always believed
this about himself
he's always said if i'm good enough then
i'm tall enough
that was the knock right he's not tall
enough when he got drafted when he was
at wisconsin
when they said we've got mike glennon
your services are no longer warranted
here at north carolina state he wasn't
tall enough
he's always believed that if i'm good
enough i'm tall enough and that's
honestly one of the things i tell my
rookies
hey if you're good enough you're old
enough these kids are starting as true
freshman in college
if you're good enough you're old enough
so whatever that insecurity is you can
absolutely solve for that
and that confidence it's not it's a
muscle if you develop it it'll grow
do you think your brother is going to
get his heisman trophy back from my man
cave
did it actually go to your man cave that
was on the list of questions i have for
you
yes yes it's it's on my bar
it's covered with dust he had it in his
garage
oh i know that i mean the last thing
he's going to do is you know
tell people how awesome he he was in
college and put pressure on his kids you
know what i mean it's the last thing
he's gonna do so
that's getting more use there than it
would that's what he said
he goes it was just in my garage and he
goes i'll ship it to you
i got its own suitcase and uh so
i think he said he was loaning it to me
i think but i
i'm just not sure i just don't know just
keep buttering up and he's got something
promoted and then i think he'll forget
about it honestly
uh i can't uh say this strongly enough
if you have a son
that is interested in playing the
position or is playing the position and
you want to hear from somebody who knows
what he's talking about
and works with deshaun watson sam
darnold josh allen most recently joe
burrow
jordan palmer is the guy it's uh
qbsummit.com a digital platform
great to touch base with you again
jordan thanks for joining us yeah thanks
a lot dan thanks guys